Put down that bull of top ramen.
Tell your mom.
No seconds on the tuna casserole please.
Because today we're going to take a look at a story of a man who is so bent on revenge
he would feed his friends.
The unthinkable.
And then we travel to Martha's Vineyard in Massachusetts where a young boy is out playing
among the sand dunes.
Little does he know he's about to see something.
No modern human was ever meant to discover.
Today on Dead Rabbit Radio.
Hey everyone welcome back to another episode of Dead Rabbit Radio.
I'm your host Jason Carpenter and I'm having a great day.
I hope you guys are having a great day too.
I hope you guys have some awesome plans for the weekend.
It's pretty much just playing a killing floor for me and doing research for even more episodes
for next week.
But someone who can't wait till next week walking into Dead Rabbit Command right now
is one of our long time legacy Patreon supporters.
Give it up for Sweet Sweet Golden Goo.
Woohoo yeah come on in.
Sticky sweets from her head to her feet.
Sweet Sweet Golden Goo you're going to be our captain, our pilot this episode.
You guys can't swear the Patreon off you guys aren't super tasty that's fine too.
Just helps read the word about the show that really really really helps out a lot.
Now we got a lot of stuff to cover today.
So let's go ahead and get started.
Sweet Sweet Golden Goo I'm going to go ahead and toss you the keys for the Dead Rabbit
Durgible.
We're going to leave behind Dead Rabbit Command.
Fly us all the way out to Quebec.
Specifically we're headed out to Saint Andy Bellevue in Quebec.
And we're going to stop by MacDonald College.
Not MacDonald's University which sounds delicious.
This story is the opposite of that.
It's the most repulsive story that you could positively think of regarding food and we've
covered a lot of gross ones.
We're at MacDonald College.
It's January 1970.
And we're walking around school and we're like in the school cafeteria and they're like
handing out like muffins and jelly and like pancakes and stuff I'm guessing.
And we're eating those and into the cafeteria walks Eric Kranz.
He's this 23 year old student who is currently researching parasiteology.
The study of parasites.
We're in the middle of taking a bite of a pancake.
I was like yeah this is a tough one.
Eric Kranz just loves to be around parasites.
He's hanging around a bunch of people who borrow money and never give a mini money back.
He's like ah my people.
He loves looking through microscopes at tiny little eggs and he probably like feeds chickens
to snakes and stuff like that.
They're like Eric stop doing that.
That's not a definition of a parasite.
He's like yeah it's just fun.
Allegedly I should mention very clearly right now this is all alleged.
Eric Kranz goes home.
Now he's currently sharing a home with four roommates.
Now they didn't get along.
This part isn't alleged.
They did not get along.
Eric Kranz and his roommates never saw eye to eye.
And this all came to a head when one day they're like hey Eric you owe us back rent.
Eric's like listen man I'm trying to get the money together.
I already loaned my money off to a bunch of people.
They're not paying me back.
Parasiteology has gone too far.
They're like Eric you gotta pay us the money.
This is insane.
Actually the thing we're gonna get to is super insane.
But this also blows my mind.
He owed them $16.66 in back rent.
Now let's forget the whole 666 thing because you know that's just creepy in and of itself.
But they were ready to evict this dude because he was short around $17.
He was $17 short on his rent and they're like bro pack your bags you gotta get out of here.
Now they didn't like the guy right.
So they're looking for any reason.
But apparently there was a lot of debate on this.
I found this story online.
It was posted by a guy named Delano 1998.
He's not a participant in this story.
Don't go after him.
Don't try to seek some parasite justice yourself.
He just posted this.
And a lot of people were debating wow $17 and he's getting kicked out.
Apparently in 1970 Canadian money that was close to about $130.
So yeah I could see if someone's behind $130 and you didn't like them.
You want to get rid of them.
So they're like Eric you gotta pay the money.
You gotta pay the money you owed to us and he's like oh he's not picking up pennies.
He's like oh now I just need $1665 more and all my troubles are solved.
He's getting so upset with these guys.
Like again it seems to be a long-brewing thing when they keep on him about paying the rent
that he owes he says quote.
This might be the most specific threat I've ever heard before.
Normally it's like I'll get you.
One of these days I'll get you.
Then you fly away in your car and inspect your gadgets like oh save the day once again.
This was his threat.
He turned to his roommates.
They said where's the $16 and 66 cents you owe us.
He's like oh he said quote all put parasites in your food and you'll wake up dead.
That is such a specific threat and it's coming from someone who could do it because he's
studying parasitology.
He has access to parasites.
Have I made that threat to someone?
You're like Jason you can barely pronounce the word.
I doubt you can rummage up more than three or four parasites which would still be too
much to be in your food.
But you're like I'm not worried about Jason and I'll be like oh get you gadget.
They're like when he's not gadget just please give me the $17 you owe me and leave.
He owes him money.
He threatens them by putting parasites in their food.
What happens is January 31st rolls around and he comes into the house and he's like
hey guys I got big news.
You're $17 and they're like oh yeah we were expecting something better than that but that's
what you owe us.
You've got to hope someone said you know big news.
But fine we'll take the $17.
He paid them the $17 and yet they evicted him anyways.
What crumbums.
All he did was threaten to put parasites in your food and you're evicting him.
He paid them money.
They evicted him.
But let bygones be bygones right?
It's the holiday spirit of Quebec because the first week of February there's a thing
called the winter carnival where people dress up like snowmen and they walk around and they
just go ho ho ho and people are like what?
It's just like a snowman.
So no one doesn't say that.
They're like just go with it.
It's Canada.
We do weird stuff up here.
They have this thing called winter carnival where they just kind of dance around.
I didn't research that at all.
I just go oh winter carnival and then I clicked on Wikipedia and it was like a picture of a
man in a snowman suit.
It's like oh that's all the research I need to do on that.
Just one photograph.
So I don't know.
It could be like some big religious festival I could have pissed off a whole nation.
Anyways winter carnival and Eric is like you know what guys?
I was the crumbum this time.
I should have paid you that $17 when I owed it.
So I have decided to serve you a feast.
And he brings in all this food he prepared for winter carnival.
Let's stop the story right here and I just this is a this isn't a choose your own adventure.
This is not a logic.
This is not a logic question.
It's not a word problem.
If someone ever threatened to put parasites in your food and then you evicted them and
then they show back up a couple days later with food would you eat it?
But you know what maybe it's a holiday spirit.
Maybe bygones be bygones right?
Old enemies become friends.
Old people who threatened to feed you parasites become people who don't do that.
And he brought in all this food and you accept it as a good friend would right?
What type of friend would you be if you didn't eat the food of a maniac who threatened to
poison you?
So his roommates and apparently like three other people there was a total of seven people
that got afflicted by what's about to happen.
But you can't you have no idea what's coming up next.
This true story.
He brings in all this food they eat it.
They're like oh this is delicious.
Oh no no no they're like fighting over the last roll.
They're like oh man oh man.
And Eric's probably just sitting there with a big old smile.
They realize it's weird he didn't eat anything.
He's like oh I had my winter festival dinner on the way over.
Go ahead and gorge yourselves on this delicious food.
About a week later all of the roommates all the four roommates get sick around the same
time.
But you know it's winter right?
pneumonia is going around.
People get sick.
They're coughing.
They're losing weight pretty rapidly right?
That's usually not a symptom of the flu.
These four roommates start to develop a fever as well.
They're sweating.
They're coughing.
They're all skinny though.
They're like oh no take it off the freshman 40.
This is great.
But then all four of them and I'm assuming the other three people showed up for this
party.
I have no idea about the cryptic threat that Eric made.
They just showed up but they don't play a lot into this later narrative.
I'm sure they were also incredibly sick.
We know about these four roommates cough, weight loss, fever and then this is the most
troubling of all right?
You can tank those other three no problem.
You're like Jason I don't know why you're so blase about having high temperature.
They start to feel all four of them feel like they can't breathe.
Now that's frightening.
But on February 12th it goes to full on they can't breathe.
Like by February 12th they are actually having a hard time taking a deep breath and they're
breaking out in hives.
So at this point it's been like two weeks at this point they go to the hospital and
they get in there and they're in respiratory distress.
The doctor's like oh no you guys should have been here a long time ago.
You guys look terrible.
But you've lost a lot of weight.
You look like pretty slim guys.
They take them in.
The doctor, the attending physician brings them in and is treating them and they start
treating them for pneumonia.
They're having trouble breathing.
All this other stuff.
So they start treating them for pneumonia and nothing is working.
And he's like the doctor's like oh man I don't know what else to do.
I did one thing.
I tried one thing and it didn't work out.
You guys will be fine.
Two of them end up in critical condition because they can't breathe.
February 16th.
Dude is coughing into like a little tray, a little spit tray.
And the nurse picks it up and she goes oh yes.
This is my favorite one of my job.
I have a fetish for phlegm.
She takes the tray of phlegm and they're looking at it.
I'm sure I don't know if they saw this with a naked eye.
But what they discovered at this point, remember they ate the food on February 1st.
The first week of February.
It's February 16th now.
They find a worm in the phlegm.
And he's coughing up.
A four millimeter long worm.
I wish I could say how big it was first you imagined a giant earthworm.
You're like nope.
You shut off the podcast.
You're like I'm done.
A four millimeter long worm just kind of squiggling around in his phlegm.
The nurse goes oh I got to tell the doctor about this and the doctor's looking at it and
he goes wow.
Who would have thought that this worm would be inside a human.
What they found, what this worm was was something known as the escarus sum.
It's a round worm found in pigs.
It lives in pig intestines.
It's a giant round worm.
They grow to be about six to twelve inches long.
They live in pig intestines.
And the doctor's like you know we've always had theories about these worms getting into
humans right because maybe like if you ate enough pork products.
When you're eating so many hot dogs you just start eating the life pig.
You're like sucking their intestines up like a string of spaghetti.
And you ate all the eggs.
So the doctor's like but this is still weird.
We don't even know if it's possible.
If it is possible it's incredibly rare.
How did all these people eat pig intestines?
We didn't eat pig intestines by the way.
The patients are like you know what this is starting to make sense because our roommate
worked in a parasitology lab.
He threatened to put parasites in our food and the doctors like okay that makes a little
more sense.
They start to do all these tests on the people and these four roommates and they find the
life cycle of this round worm in these four dudes.
What happens is there's microscopic eggs in their bloodstream that float out of the intestines
into the bloodstream and then go into the lung.
That's why they were having such trouble breathing.
And part of the life cycle is you would cough up this larva because the egg hatches in your
lungs so now you got this little worm in you and then you would cough it up along with
all the other phlegm and sputum.
Right?
Apparently that's the thing.
I think it's just a fancy word for phlegm but I think it's like bloody phlegm.
Jason please.
Please just quit giving the visuals.
They're coughing up these little worms, these little immature worms and they climb up the
trachea.
And then you swallow them back down and they go back into your stomach where they become
mature worms.
Out of your intestines, into your blood, into your lungs, coughing out of your lungs back
in your stomach.
The worms journey is complete.
So what they did was they go we got to get rid of these worms even though this is kind
of cool scientifically.
We got to get rid of the worms, the attending physicians, started them on this treatment
that's used to kill this type of parasite.
Pretty much ends the infestation right there.
But they have like, you figure, okay Jason they have a couple of worms.
Big deal, big deal.
They have a couple of worms in them.
One of the dudes was full of at least, at least they probably lost count after a certain
point.
He had at least 400,000 larva larvae inside of him.
400,000 wriggling little worms crawling through his body.
He's all being tickled all the time.
He's like, "I didn't know it would be so fun."
Trying to throw him up.
One dude, it was just coming out of his bowel movements, right?
Just worms.
He's going poop.
A bunch of worms are coming out.
I would rather be tickled by 400,000 worms than to have one worm come out of my butthole.
The doctor said, "This is real serious."
He goes, "One of these guys, one of these patients, he's going to have permanent
lung damage."
Like these worms did such a number on him that he's going to have lung damage for the
rest of his life.
Eric, after the roommates and the friends started getting sick, he left Quebec.
He ditched the place.
He's like, "I'm done."
And once his scheme was undone, right?
Once they figured out what had happened, they actually set out in a restaurant for attempted
murder.
On March 9th, 1970, he surrendered himself and they let him out on bail.
They figured, "What's the worst you can do?
What's the worst this guy can do with a super villain?"
He can just infest the world with parasites.
They let him out on bail.
June 1971 is when the trial took place.
And the prosecution was like, "What evidence, what possible evidence do you need?"
He worked at a parapsytology lab.
He had access to parasites.
He threatened to give people parasites.
People he didn't like had parasites.
And here's a bunch of photos.
X-rays of them boogying down in this dude's stomach.
Case closed.
Like, who else could possibly do this?
Now, his defense lawyer said, "Your Honor, parasites, schmericides."
He totally blew off the whole thing.
He goes, "Listen, sure my client worked at a parasite lab, but who knows where they
got these parasites?
It turns out that their kitchen sink was constantly full of sewage for some reason.
I know college life was hard.
But that's what the defense lawyer said.
And the other roommates were like, "No, that's not true.
That's not true."
Their eyes shift from side to side.
They're like, "Okay, it's a little true."
But there wasn't so much sewage in our sink that we got parasites.
And the defense lawyer was like, "Mm-hmm."
And then the defense lawyer goes, "Okay, well maybe it's not the sewage theory.
However, yes, my client did work at a parasite lab.
But this could happen accidentally.
You see, my client may have gotten some eggs on his clothes.
Some microscopic eggs, you wouldn't even see him, right?
He's walking around the lab in his blue jeans and his polo and a couple of roundworm eggs
end up all over his clothes.
It happens to the vestibulus.
And then his roommates, maybe when they were kicking him out.
I don't know, maybe they were going through his clothes.
Maybe they were packing his bags for him.
Who am I to say?
But it's possible that this guy who threatened to put eggs in people's food didn't actually
do it.
It was an accident from them handling his clothes.
And Eric won the case.
Eric was acquitted of this crime.
He served no jail time for poisoning seven people.
Sometimes I wrap up these true crime stories with some sort of lesson to be learned or
some sort of look at the justice system and how corrupt it can be and how they can miss
the mark.
I don't know if there's anything like this.
I think the moral of this story is if somebody ever threatens to poison you with parasites,
do not eat their food.
The fact that he got off is it should be shocking, but Canadian justice system is just awful.
And this guy's still out there, right?
He was 23 in 1970, so that would make him.
You're like, "Oh, great, Jason's going to try to do math."
This is how I do math.
They go 70 plus 90 is 20, so then he'd be 43 in 1990, and then he'd be 53 in 2000.
This is really how I do math.
This guy would be 75 years old now.
He could still be out there.
He could be working at a local restaurant.
We are at right now.
If you listen into the squad guest, you're still eating your noodles.
I told you not to, and then you look over and you see in the kitchen, there's a man
standing there with a glimmer in his eye and a parasite coming out of his other eye.
This guy's probably dead by now.
This guy's messing around with parasites.
This guy's constantly juggling roundworm eggs.
He probably infested himself at some point, but it's crazy, bizarre, true crime story
and absolutely disgusting and lesson or not whether or not there's moral to what I just
wanted to share it with you.
Sweet, sweet golden goo.
Grab that barf bag, get it over with, and I'm going to toss you the keys to the carbon
acopter.
We're leaving behind Quebec.
We're headed all the way out to Martha's Vineyard.
The year is 2002.
It's a beautiful summer and we're spending it in Martha's Vineyard.
Martha's Vineyard in Massachusetts.
Now, the story was posted online by someone going by the name, "You're doing great, sweaty."
I think they might have misspelled, sweetie.
You're doing great, sweaty.
We're going to go ahead and call this dude Samuel.
He tells the story.
This actually happened back when he was between the ages of eight and 10, back in the year
2002.
He goes, "Listen, I've never told this story before.
I've never told it to anybody except for my parents because they were there and they wanted
answers."
Back in 2002, Samuel's family, mom, dad, and him, took a vacation out to Martha's Vineyard.
He goes, "Listen, I was an excitable child.
I was always running around and tugging on people's shirts and picking their pockets.
I was a regular Aladdin.
I was constantly wanting to explore nature.
My parents were like, "Sure, Sam, go away.
Go away playing the bushes.
Have fun."
Somewhere far away from us.
They fed into his need to explore.
When they went to Martha's Vineyard, they're actually out on the beach.
He believes this is somewhere near the Menemasha Hills Beach.
They're out the beach just having a good time.
Everyone's at the beach having a good time.
It's really hard to be depressed at the beach.
Maybe you just got stung by jellyfish and you're watching somebody unzip their pants
ready to pee on you.
That's probably the most depressed you could be at the beach.
But little Sam, he's running around.
Woohoo!
Yeah, this is so much fun.
And he sees there's this tall series of rocks that some of the teens are climbing up and
jumping off the rocks into the water.
And he's like, "Wow, that looks fun, but even being a little eight-year-old, I know that's
extremely dangerous.
I want to go exploring instead of risking paralyzation."
So he decides, "I'm going to see what's on the other side of those rocks.
Just go for a little kid journey."
So he goes over the rocks.
He's kind of walking along and he says, "I'm probably about a half a mile at this point,
a half a mile from where my parents and everyone else is.
I'm kind of alone at this point.
I see these huge sand dunes."
Now I actually looked, I couldn't find this exact location.
I tried looking for this exact location on Google Earth, but I did find, I was looking
at this beach area.
And it's interesting because you have beach and then immediately, like it's like sand
and then heavy greenery.
It's just like goes from straight beach to grass.
In California, it was never like that.
Like you had the beach, they needed a bunch of rocks that you'd cut your feet on and then
you had a bunch of paved stuff.
Usually referred to as a parking lot.
And then you just had more kind of dusty mountains, kind of rocky mountains and not the rocky
mountains, but you know, and it was kind of laid out like that, right?
It was a clear definition between the biomes, but here it's not the case.
It goes beach, then lush foliage.
So he's climbing up these huge sand dunes.
He says they're about 75 to 100 feet tall.
That might be the exaggeration of an eight year old boy, right?
Or to an eight year old, everything may seem that tall.
But he's climbing these dunes and he gets up on the top one of these dunes and he goes,
"I'm going to see if I can see my family.
I'm going to get at the top of this dune and I'm going to see if I can see past the big
rocks and apparently I have the vision of a superhero.
See if I can see my family way, way over there.
See if I can pick out my parents from a half a mile away."
Now he gets at the top of the hill and he can't really see anyone.
He can't see his parents.
He's pretty far away.
But what he does see at the top of the sand dune, because again, it has this giant lump
in the earth right next to it.
It's literally like in the sand, they're like budding up against each other.
Are these huge bushes?
And he turns and he looks and in one of the bushes is a cave.
Now not like the bush was on a mountain hiding a cave.
He said, "It looked like someone actually cut a tunnel through a bush."
He's sitting there and he's looking at it.
He goes, "That's pretty weird.
I've never seen anything like this before.
It looks like someone actually took the time to bore a passageway through this bush."
And as a young adventurer, he knew that he had to see what was going on.
So he starts kind of squatting down and walking through this bush.
It apparently is like a thorn bush.
And this kid doesn't have his shirt.
So he's being super careful.
He's not throwing his arms.
I'm going, "Wee, wee!"
He's got to keep it up close to his body and kind of squatting through.
And he's walking and then he sees a slide.
Not an actual metal slide, but the earth again looks like it's been formatted as some sort
of slope.
Totally man-made.
Begins to crouch through it and go down this slide.
He said it had to be about 40 feet going down.
40 feet, you know, gradual slope.
And when he gets to the bottom of that, he is now standing in a clearing.
There's greenery all around him.
Now he's left the beach, which again is only maybe about 40 feet away.
And he's in this lush greenery.
And he says this was, again, it was a clearing.
I'm standing in this clearing, but everything else was covered by plant life, including
the sky.
There's the canopy of bushes and vines.
Maybe not vines.
He didn't specifically get transported to the lost city of gold in the Yucatan or anything.
But he says, "Even the sky was blocked out by the greenery."
And I'm looking around and it felt like someone had made a home inside of a giant bush.
He sees another tunnel leading away from this clearing and he walks down that.
And at that point he begins to hear voices.
Can't tell what they're saying.
Can kind of tell where they're coming from.
It sounds like they're coming from the end of this tunnel, but his curiosity is peaked.
He's a young boy who goes on adventures all the time.
He wants to see, he goes, "I wanted to meet the king of the fort."
Like to him, this was some sort of place, some hidden habitat.
And there had to be a king and he was going to meet him.
He was going to have so much fun with his new friends.
So he's walking through this tunnel that's built into this foliage.
And as he's getting towards the end of it, he sees another clearing, a larger clearing.
And he sees what he describes as a campfire.
But he goes, "I can't really say that I saw flames.
What I saw was a white, yellow, orange light in this clearing."
I assumed it was a campfire, but at this point he says his recollection begins to become blurry.
He has a hard time remembering super concrete details, but this is what he does remember.
He's looking through this tunnel.
He sees the other clearing and what he sees around it is a group of figures.
A group of... he doesn't like using the word "people" to describe them.
He kept putting people in air quotes or rail quotes because this is typed out, but he wasn't
comfortable using the word "people."
They seemed like something else to him.
And at this point is when he begins to feel fear.
He was totally enthusiastic about meeting the king of the fort until he gets a glimpse
of who is in the clearing.
Just a fleeting glimpse, right?
Again, he can't specifically say they were human, but this is when fear begins to overtake
him.
He starts to become terrified and specifically gets the thought that, "Oh my God, no one's
ever going to see me again."
And once he comes to that conclusion, once he comes to the conclusion, no one will ever
find me again.
He actually makes an audible gasp and the figures turn to face him.
He said, "One of them began running straight towards me, straight towards the tunnel I
was in."
And he goes, "Listen, it looked human."
I'm not going to say that they were some sort of alien or monster, but they looked human,
which is a very interesting wiggle word, right?
It's like his soul, it's like his senses were telling them they're not human.
They may look human, but they're not human.
He said, "This one that's running towards me seems to be holding some sort of long object."
He compared it to a staff or a spear, and he said this man was wearing a ceremonial headdress.
He goes, "The best I can compare it to is a stereotypical headdress of a Native American."
He goes, "I'm watching this guy run towards me.
He's angry.
He's running towards me.
I'm standing in this tunnel.
I turn and I run as fast as I can.
I get to that first clearing, and then I realize that it's a 40-foot ascent, right?
Up this slide, up this slope, and that tunnel is smaller.
It's full of thorns.
This young boy with no shirt begins to run up this slope as best as he can, squatting
when he can.
But the bramble is scratching him, poking him, cutting him, leaving thin rivers of blood
dripping out of the wounds across his body.
He finally gets to the top of the tunnel, bursts out of the clearing, and at this point he's
standing on the top of this sand dune, and he sees an older couple walking down on the
beach.
Now he feels like this pursuer, the king of the fort, is right behind him.
He doesn't turn to look.
He just begins to run down the sand dune, screaming at the top of his lungs, waving his hands,
looking for any sort of help.
This is like, you're at the beach, and you'll change viewpoint.
You're at the beach with your lovely wife, and all of a sudden a bloody eight-year-old
boy comes bursting out of the bushes, running and probably rolling down a sand dune, screaming
about something was chasing him.
What he figured, he goes, "I..."
The way that I was so scared, the way that everything was going on, he goes, "Realistically,
I was in the bushes for about five minutes."
But the whole ordeal felt like it took a half hour.
I know I wasn't in there for a half hour, but that was a level of fear that I hadn't
ever come across.
You're being pursued by something in an area you're not familiar with.
Running up the slope, all getting cut up, something like that.
It's the theory of relativity, but your hot hand on the stove, a second feels like a minute.
Only he's reunited with his parents.
They are furious.
Furious.
He'd been missing for almost three hours.
He left them.
Like he always does, he goes off on these little exploring adventures.
It took him a while to realize that he hadn't come back.
It's been a little bit longer.
They're vacationing in this area.
He doesn't know the environment.
Once they started looking for him, they began walking up and down the beach, looking for
him.
For over two hours, the search continued until finally they found each other.
When he told his parents what happened about the bush, about the man, they didn't believe
him.
They 100% thought he was making it up because he knew he was in trouble for being gone so
long.
He couldn't figure that out.
He was only gone for five minutes.
He knew it wasn't that.
Well, he knew it definitely wasn't a couple hours.
He said it felt like 30 minutes.
I think it was really only five minutes.
They were telling me I was gone for hours.
That's not how it happened.
He goes, "I just don't really know what to make of this whole experience."
This happened back in 2002.
He's posting about it 20 years later.
He goes, "I really just don't know what to think about the whole thing."
It happened.
It was real.
But what was it?
He goes, "I've even been back to Martha's Vineyard multiple times since."
Couldn't find the claring.
Couldn't find the tunnel.
Couldn't find him.
Such an interesting story.
A lot of people online when they were talking about this trying to tell sweaty, maybe it
was the Faye.
Maybe it was this fairy, "I don't like the Faye stuff.
I just think it's kind of boring."
The Faye, right?
They were abducting children.
They're holding spears and chasing children through the bushes.
"I'm all boring.
They have a bunch of tight-up kids."
I was like, "If you guys were abducted by aliens, then I'd save you."
Faye.
People are saying maybe it was the Faye.
I think they're only getting that because those dummies live in bushes too.
Some people thought they could have actually been humans.
Actual Native Americans still living in the bushes around Martha's Vineyard, which actually
sounds less plausible than the Faye.
I did an episode a long time ago.
I don't remember what episode it was, but I do think there probably is America so big.
There might be one or two lost tribes in America that we've just never stumbled across.
I actually think I said there might be a lost group of pilgrims somewhere in the middle
of the United States, like a straight-up little house on the prairie town of maybe like 23
people or whatever, in the middle of some godforsaken wilderness.
They were just fine, right?
But we don't know that they're there.
There's places in America that have never been explored.
But Martha's Vineyard, around on the coastline, it's less likely that it would be in a tourist
destination like Martha's Vineyard.
But possible right could have been humans.
But remember, he wasn't describing them as humans.
They were human alike.
They were "people."
Inner-dimensional, maybe?
Maybe they were people, but it was some sort of time distortion.
The fact of that, let's say that it was some sort of like he traveled back in time.
The fact that the bushes were kind of like the tunnel was made into the bushes, that,
even I don't know how to classify this.
Because if it was a time travel thing, he would have just walked around the corner and
saw a bunch of Native Americans standing there and they're like, "Hey, what's up?"
And then they chase it with the spear.
The fact that it was a tunnel, it was almost like it was leading him down this passageway,
right?
It was almost like a hidden gateway into some place he shouldn't be.
You're like, "Yeah, Jason, the fairies do that.
I don't want to talk about fairies, man.
I don't think it's fairies."
And what if there's some sort of nature spirit that has wings and they have little wands
and stuff like that and they grant wishes?
Forgive the fairies.
Forgive the fey.
Could be.
You know, here's the thing.
I'll tell you exactly this.
When I read the story the very first time, I thought, the first thing that popped in my
head was they were real people and it was a cult.
It was like a myth-risk cult.
It was like this old religion that's been long wiped from the history books, but yet
people still worship this deity.
That's what I, that was the feeling I got from it right away.
Was that they were people.
Like, the fact that he was having things like a blurry memory, the fact that he didn't actually
say they were human.
A lot of that stuff I chalk up to him being eight, right?
And being terrified.
I was reading it.
I was like, let's look at it rationally, right?
Martha's Vineyard, a bunch of rich people.
The elite, right, who worship these old gods, who follow these pagan ways, are having a
retreat in the bush.
Okay, that sounds kind of dumb too because everyone's like, "Hey, hey, George Soros, where
are you going?"
He's like, "I got some business in the bush, isn't there?"
"What are you doing?"
And then you see this old dude like crawling down.
He's crawling down.
He's crawling through the ramble here and...
Oh, oh, oh.
People are like, "What?"
That's super weird.
I saw a couple of Rothschilds and a couple of Rockefellers going there.
What?
Why is Jeff Bezos taking his shirt off to go down that slide into that bush?
Okay, so maybe the best place for the elite to meet, to worship an old pagan lord, where
he is in a bunch of thorn bushes, straight off of a beach at Martha's Vineyard.
And that was the first idea that I had, was that not that I wanted to see Jeff Bezos with
no shirt on, getting scratched up.
It was that I thought this was human.
It was some old cult or old religion but new followers type of thing.
That was the feeling I got.
But whether it's something cool, like my idea, like my totally awesome idea that it's a cult,
or something lame, like the Faye, the point is that it's creepy.
Because it touches on all of our fears, right?
The idea that you can go missing at any point, like he thought, "I'll never be seen again."
We cover so many stories where people just disappear, missing 4011, that's pretty much
all they talk about.
The idea that you, or one of your loved ones, could walk outside and just never be seen
again is terrifying.
But it also touches on the fear of the other, right?
This group holding these secret ceremonies just out of view.
And us normal people who go about our lives, we don't realize that just maybe 500 yards
underneath us, or 60 feet away in the bushes, or maybe in your own attic, maybe in your
own attic, there are these secret rituals going on.
There's these gatherings, there are these ceremonies taking place.
We're just completely oblivious to it.
It's creepy to think that these things may exist, and that this boy came across one of
these and probably did just barely escape.
This story could have easily ended.
Well, it wouldn't have been a story, right?
We never would have out here on the West Coast.
Maybe we would have covered a story about a little boy who went missing back in 2002 at
Martha's Vineyard, right?
Maybe it could just be one of many missing persons cases that happen, and everyone but
the family and friends of the victim, just forget about it and move on.
Whether the story is paranormal, conspiracy, or true crime, right?
It could have been any of those three, or all.
It's still a reminder that as much as we want to believe it, we are not.
We are not the masters of the domain.
We are not the rulers of the earth.
We're simply bystanders, participants.
We don't make the rules.
We only follow them.
That is the way of this world.
Whether we like it or not, you can only hope that if you ever come across a situation where
you're confronted by a king of the fort, you also can outrun him.
Whether it's trying to find your way through a tunnel in a clearing of bushes, or booking
it down a dark street as shadowy agents follow your every move.
Whether it's standing at a bus stop late at night, and you can sense eyes staring at you
from the alleyway across the street, or you're simply sleeping in your bed and you have no
knowledge that some dark cult or some malignant entity has chosen you as its next sacrifice.
The only thing you can hope for, the only thing any of us can hope for is that when
our time comes, when we are put in a situation where we are confronted by this type of oppressor,
the only thing we can hope for if we're ever put in such a dire circumstance, whether we
looked for it or not, whether we went exploring in the bushes or in the safety of our own
home.
We can only hope that we survive to tell the tale.
(upbeat music)